Speaker 1: Welcome back to the David Pakman
show. I am Ferron Cousins from Ring of Fire
sitting in for David today. And if you want,
you can follow me across social media, Twitter,
Facebook and Instagram. I'm at Ferran. Balanced.
I would appreciate any follows. You may throw my
way. But until then, let's get back to some more
of the biggest stories of this week and one of
the more grotesque things that we saw happen this
week, in addition to Marjorie Taylor Greene's week
long meltdown. She took a minor break from that to
tell a British reporter, go back to your country.
Now we have the clip on my show in just a minute.
But before I do, let me go ahead and set up,
you know, set the stage for you, if I might. What
happened here is that Republicans in the Senate.
Worked with the Democrats. They came up with
their bipartisan gun control legislation,
long overdue, decades overdue, really. And
finally, we got it. Not quite as strong as
we needed it, but hey, we got something. And
sometimes you got to celebrate even the smallest
victories, even if it's not what you wanted. You
got to take the wins when you can get them. But
Marjorie Taylor GREENE was angry, angry, my
friends, angry that those Senate Republicans
dared to join with those Democrats
and take away your guns, as she says.
So she holds a press conference with a couple of
other weirdos from Congress, including, of course,
Lauren Boebert, Thomas Massie and Andrew Clyde.
When she was confronted by British reporter
and then this exchange took place. Here it is.
Speaker 2: And it's our job to defend the Second
Amendment, understand that we don't have guns
in the U.K. That is true, but we don't have mass
shootings either. Children aren't scared to go.
You have mass stabbings, lady. You have all kinds
of murder. We've got laws and nothing. That is
same rights. Well, you can go back to your country
and worry about your. No. We like ours here.
Speaker 1: Go back to your country.
You have mass stabbings,
lady. Okay. But. Not really.
Certainly not at the level that we see
mass shootings here in the United States,
even before we had the big string of mass
shootings taking place in America in May.
Even before that, statistics already showed
us that we were averaging here in this country
ten mass shootings per week. Little more
than one per day. And that, of course,
is a mass shooting defined as any single shooter
event in which four or more people are shot.
More than one per day here in the United States.
Great Britain is not suffering a mass stabbing
every day. I don't even know if they're suffering
a mass stabbing every, you know, four months,
as Marjorie Taylor GREENE wants to make it seem.
The homicide rate here in the United States is
four times higher. Then over in Great Britain,
four times higher. And 80% of those homicides.
Guns. That's what's killing people 80% of the
time here in the United States, when some person
kills another one, guns. That's the difference.
Mass stabbings are not something that people
in the United Kingdom walk around terrified
of every single day versus here in the United
States. You're not safe in a grocery store. Our
kids aren't safe in school. You're not safe
in a house of worship. You're not safe at a
music festival. You're not safe at a mall.
You're not safe walking down the street.
You're not safe. Plain and simple. You're not
safe here in the United States from gun violence.
It doesn't matter where you are,
where you live. Red state. Blue state.
Yes. Some states do have higher rates, of course.
But you go over to the UK. You don't see people
cowering in fear all the time. You don't see
them out there saying the only thing that stops a
bad guy with a knife is a good guy with a knife.
They don't come up with
those idiotic talking points.
But we do here in the United States,
partly because we have elected
officials like Marjorie Taylor GREENE,
who, rather than address the facts,
rather than acknowledge that this is a
uniquely American phenomenon, because it is,
she would rather insult that reporter
telling her, go back to your country.
I mean, we have seen, obviously, these hard core
hate mongers across the United States. I mean,
for centuries telling people, go back to your
country. But here we have in the year 2022
an elected member of Congress telling
another human being, go back to your country.
Are we even redeemable as a society? Are we
redeemable as a country? If this is what we've
got representing us, this is now the global
face of the United States. And it really is.
You know, I get emails, I get comments, I get all
kinds of things from people all over the world.
The talk about Marjorie Taylor GREENE that talk
about Lauren Boebert or Matt Gaetz or of course,
Donald Trump. The rest of the world does see these
things. And this is the face that we put forward.
And I know this is just one individual
from a tiny little county in Georgia.
Who has somehow become the crazy global
face of what the United States is all about.
And it all goes back to comments like that,
telling a reporter. Go back to your country